good evening everyone and welcome to the
86th Academy Awards scientific and
technical awards and I am absolutely
delighted to be sharing the stage with
you Cheryl I know everyone in this room
extends their congratulations for the
great job you're doing as our president
thank you Richard and I want to thank
you for all your efforts and dedication
as a governor and chair of the
scientific and technical awards main
committee and we would like to thank
everyone who's worked hard so hard to
make this evening possible the
scientific and technical awards main
committee and the digital imaging
technology committee if you would all
please stand
and we would also like to acknowledge
all the Academy governors who are here
tonight would you all please stand
and I would like to thank our academy
staff a wonderful group of professionals
we appreciate all that you do and I'd
also like to thank the Academy Science
and Technology Council which continues
to play a leading role in the important
technology issues facing our industry in
the past year alone the Academy's aces
program saw increase adoption with
several big studio releases our digital
dilemma reports were translated into
marathi and korean a delegation from the
saitek council traveled to Mumbai and
Delhi to meet with the government and
filmmakers and the council is currently
shooting a series of shorts as part of
its next generation cinema technology
test materials program the Academy from
its earliest days has been committed to
the advancement of technology and to
recognizing individuals who have made
major contributions to science and
technology and cinema tonight we're here
to recognize your accomplishments and to
celebrate the extraordinary innovations
you've brought to the industry very good
tonight's awards cover a broad range of
technology from pneumatic tire flipping
to fantastic creature creature creations
in ZBrush in and also the blue do that
you all do so well the sheer number of
awards were giving out tonight reflects
the explosion of the new technology that
we're experiencing speaking of which
please put your phones on vibrate and
keep your speeches breathe we have an
exciting evening ahead and welcome again
and we'll be back with the show after a
short break